mourning the killing of Palestinian or
theita Mimi life in the occupied West
Bank came to a standstill held by many
Palestinians as a national hero they say
the 22 year old was able to elude one of
the most advanced armies in the world
Tamimi had been on the Run since the
Israeli Army said he killed one of its
soldiers in a gun attack nearly two
weeks ago late on Wednesday he was
killed during a shootout with guards at
an illegal Israeli settlement east of
Jerusalem
in a will set to be written by him
Tamimi asked Palestinians to take up
arms to fight against Israel's
occupation
what they did for the country makes us
proud the video shows how he kept
fighting till the end we're proud of him
he's with God now
this sense of defiance has been seen
across the West Bank in Hebron nablis
and Ramallah confrontations with Israeli
forces broke out as young men took to
the streets to express anger and
frustration
even if you were a spoil for Israel you
would become a fighter now we as mothers
are getting heartbroken you can imagine
the young men when they see others
getting killed each day
Israeli authorities did not return to
Mimi's body to his family his father
told Al Jazeera they were not contacted
so they could see his body
we opened a morning site here because
oday's mother is under house arrest so
we're holding two wakes a lot of people
are here to pay their respects
in the West Bank another week was held
following the funeral of a 16 year old
Muhammad Nuri died of wounds sustained
last month Israeli soldiers shot him
during a protest near the illegal
Israeli settlement of betel this year
more than 120 Palestinians were killed
by Israeli forces in the West Bank
including veteran Al Jazeera journalist
chirin about
she was targeted and shot dead while on
assignment in Janine nearly six months
ago
without accountability attacks on
journalists continue many here say that
Israel doesn't want the world to see the
real face of occupation
Ibrahim al-jazeera be occupied West Bank